it would be a shock to me if they were
to search the offices and Residences of
cabinet members for example
um maybe not Secretary of the Interior
but certainly like Secretary of State as
an example I would be shocked if there
weren't some classified documents at the
homes of others as well Democrats
Republicans notice I'm not mentioning
partisan politics here is it ridiculous
or is it to be expected I don't know you
know the truth is that elected officials
review thousands or tens of thousands of
files when they're in office things get
moved around things could get misfiled
misclassified misplaced whatever it's
not a defense by the way I believe every
one of these cases should be
investigated and I'll get to that in a
moment but when you are dealing with
this volume of documents and you're
dealing with human beings after all it's
not a huge shock what it shouldn't be is
a partisan issue